colombia entrará en una nueva fase sin
cuarentena a partir del primero de
septiembre la medida pondrá fin a uno de
los confinamientos más extensos del
mundo ya que de forma parcial o total se
han restringido los movimientos de los
ciudadanos desde el 25 de marzo en el
primero de septiembre empieza una nueva
fase donde cambiamos el concepto de
aislamiento preventivo obligatorio con
un número importante de excepciones a
que tengamos un concepto de aislamiento
selectivo de distanciamiento y
responsabilidad individual
bogotá la capital del país y la ciudad
más afectada finalizará sus cuarentenas
el miércoles en la noche el encierro
prolongado ha causado que el pib
colombiano cayese un 74 por ciento en el
primer semestre del año algo que han
sentido especialmente los comerciantes
que horas antes del anuncio salieron en
bogotá a protestar por su situación la
falta de ayudas durante estos meses ha
causado que en numerosos
establecimientos se hayan visto
obligados a cerrar cinco meses golpeados
económicamente por
parte de la administración distrital
aquí están hablando de ayudas a los
comerciantes para que a sus empleados
les lleguen subsidios eso no es cierto
no han llegado pero el virus está lejos
de ser controlado en colombia el país
registra cifras de contagio superiores a
los 10 mil casos diarios y los decesos
oscilan entre los 250 y los 400 diarios
en las últimas semanas